welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler and i am
the special temporary primary host
and that is a temporary position but the
primary is really the operative term
there that's the key word uh if you were
to construct hypothetically like
a podium of all the different hosts of
the stronger by science podcast without
question i'd be in the number one spot
in the front and center kind of towering
over all others but today i am joined by
greg knuckles he is currently the
permanent guest co-host for the show
at least for the time being so greg
thank you for joining me
thanks for having me on uh and and just
to add to
that analogy uh all of the
uh guest co-hosts and all of the other
laborers who make this podcast possible
we would be the foundation upon which
the podium rests uh for two reasons
one the primary host as the
dirty bourgeois capitalist in this
situation uh which i take as a
compliment by the way which you
shouldn't uh walks all over the labor
that that makes all of this possible but
we are
also the foundation that allows
anything else to exist without us the
podium itself would just be falling and
spiraling down into an endless void
cool sounds good
all right so
if you enjoy the show and you would like
to support it there are many ways to do
it you could like rate or subscribe
wherever you access podcasts
you could go to
bulksupplements.com and use our discount
code that is sbs pod and it gets you a
five percent discount off your entire
order
of course you could also subscribe to
the mass research review or you could
subscribe to macro factor which is our
diet app which does offer a free trial
uh greg road to the stage how are things
going
uh things are going pretty well um
so
march ended up being
an unintentional diet break month um
i was on vacation for a week and
otherwise sticking to my numbers pretty
good and body just decided nah not going
to lose weight uh but
it more recently decided yeah let's
start let's start losing weight again uh
so yeah hit a new all-time well not all
time i i was a baby once uh hitting new
within the past decade low of 2 30 on
the dot this morning
and i am going to call my shot probably
by the time this episode actually goes
out we're we're recording this on monday
it'll go out on thursday
i think i'll probably have a day
somewhere in the 220s by then if not
definitely by the time we record next
week i'm going to
break through
that barrier which until this point many
people believe to be humanly impossible
uh and yeah uh things are going well
very close to the 220s very stoked about
that
awesome that's fantastic um
we will see if you successfully call
your shot or not i i'm excited to see
that
uh i don't have any updates for the road
to athens uh my body continues to betray
me on a regular basis but i'm excited
pretty soon since the weather is heating
up i'll be able to do more cross
training a little bit more swimming a
little bit more paddle boarding uh i'm
really excited about that so i'll
probably have more updates in the coming
weeks cool um all right before we so we
have a lot to cover today we've got
quite a few uh listener questions that
we would like to answer and discuss but
before we do that i understand you've
got a research review and this is a very
timely research review uh so it is
early to mid april in north carolina
uh beautiful place to be a lot of lovely
trees lovely flowers but around this
time of year it is very dangerous to go
outside uh for someone like me the the
allergy season is in full swing uh so
greg what do you have for us
uh yeah so i will neither confirm nor
deny that i also struggle with allergies
uh
that would be a hipaa violation uh but
theoretically maybe i do um and what i'm
about to talk about is something that
in an ideal world i would remember at
the start of every allergy season and i
always forget until
about a month into allergy season
but yes i think for
the first time on the podcast this is a
dedicated greg
supplement section that comes with a
recommendation
i've talked about supplements before
generally it's in the context of a
segment that you initiate since you're
the supplement guy uh but when it comes
when it comes to stuffy noses i i am
your guy i maybe struggle with that more
than
uh most people alive
so it's it's something that's very near
and dear
both to my heart and my sinus passages
well and by definition if anyone
struggled more than you with this they
would not be alive
i mean that is kind of true like i i've
had to be hospitalized for
like allergic reactions and you know not
not like uh i have a peanut allergy and
i need an epipen but just like when i
was a kid before i got allergy shots um
occasionally the pollen would just be so
bad that
all my [ __ ] would swell up and i
couldn't breathe i need to go to the
hospital i shouldn't be laughing no i
mean uh yeah no i
i
should not have survived childhood
honestly it is an abomination of modern
medicine that i'm still here today
no i i had to go to the hospital for
[ __ ] seasonal allergies related to
pollen i had to go to i was hospitalized
for um
uh like poison ivy infections so when i
get poisoned i we're already off the
rails but when i get poison ivy man um
and again not as bad anymore since i've
had allergy shots but when i was a kid
i would get like a little patch of
poison ivy on my body and i don't fully
understand how this works but it would
it would just go systemic and i'd wake
up the next day and like 25 of my flesh
would just be covered with poison ivy
and then
i'm basically just crossing my fingers
and hoping and praying that it wouldn't
make it into my uh like my trachea the
next day uh and sometimes it would i'd
wake up throat would be somewhere
between itchy and painful very a lot of
difficulty breathing i didn't know that
like glandular tissue
and who knows maybe it wasn't actually
poison ivy bumps on my [ __ ] maybe it was
just like so much generalized in uh
inflammation from
all of the poison ivy on my body but
yeah just wake up unable to breathe um
so yeah allergies not not my friend so
uh yeah let's talk about uh allergies a
little bit so we're talking about
we looked up the pronunciation before
this started spirulina right yes
spirulina um
i i'm so bad about that because i don't
i don't talk about
fitnessy or supplement related things
outside of the podcast for the most part
because like i mean
when you're over here working we do but
otherwise like i'm hanging out with
lindsay she doesn't want to talk about
that stuff so there are so many words
that i read but then i realized i've
never said and it's podcast time and i'm
like oh [ __ ] anyway spirulina um
it's it's cool stuff
it's a blue green
algae that can be
basically just like dried out you can
take it in tablet or pill form
and there is some evidence that it is
pretty effective for cutting down on
allergic rhinitis symptoms rhinitis just
means inflammation of the nose and nasal
passages
rhyne like rhino either the greek or
latin word for nose i think greek i
don't know doesn't matter an itis that's
the the suffix for inflammation so
inflammation of the nose um
so
there have been two studies looking at
the impact of spirulina supplementation
on allergic rhinitis symptoms uh and i
was going to talk about those two
studies
individually uh but then i came across a
pre-printed systematic review by batista
and colleagues uh called efficacy of
spirulina for allergic rhinitis um and
so i'm just going to put that in the
show notes instead as my reference one
because it talks about like it reviews
both of the studies that have looked at
this uh and two i found it
i found it very cute because it was a
systematic review of two papers and i've
never seen a systematic review
of that few studies before and to be
clear it's a pre-print who knows if
it'll make it through peer review
if it doesn't it will probably get
rejected because it's a systematic
review of two papers but in terms of how
it was conducted uh you know it followed
the cochrane recommendations its actual
discussion of the two primary studies
was solid so like the information is
good i just found it funny that that
it's a systematic review of two studies
did they do a quantitative meta-analysis
with it they didn't because the the two
studies looked at um slightly different
endpoints and i mean maybe they didn't
plan on doing a meta-analysis in the
first place a meta of two studies would
be even funnier yeah but yeah because
i'm thinking you know maybe you cut them
some slack because they're like hey
let's do a systematic review maybe they
were anticipating that there would be a
a more um
you know a larger body of literature and
then they they do their systematic
search and they say oh
we only caught two yeah yeah um but yeah
so the the two papers one is by
uh sinji and colleagues from 2005 and
one is more recent by newlyon
and colleagues from 2020
and in both of these studies they used
two grams of spirulina per day as the
treatment dose uh the the earlier study
compared it against placebo and the more
recent study uh compared it against uh
citizen which is the generic name for
the brand the brand name drug zyrtec
um
and in in both of these studies like
they looked at a variety of different
endpoints
um
which
is like
most of them were self-report so it's
like hey how runny is your nose how
itchy is your nose is it more or less
runny or itchy than before um
and and across those kind of
self-reported measures um spirulina
worked pretty well both within group led
to reductions in those nasal allergy
symptoms over time
in the earlier study that compared it
against placebo pretty much washed a
placebo treatment in in virtually
everything which is what you like to see
and in the more recent study that
compared it against uh cetirazine it did
about as well as ceterizine for a
variety of symptoms and actually
performed better than cetarizine for
a few other symptoms which
which is pretty cool from an herbal
supplement um
but yeah overall seems like spirulina
works pretty well in terms of how it
works um
it it seems to reduce the cytokine
response to
um
things that would tend to cause allergic
symptoms and that is probably downstream
of spirulina blocking histamine release
from mast cells so
um
you know what i was i was going to talk
through the biochemical pathways of
allergic reactions
a bunch of big words no one's going to
remember it anyway who cares basically a
lot of stuff happens but one of the
first thing that one of the first things
that happens is
like when an allergic response is
triggered is histamine is released from
mast cells that histamine binds to
histamine receptors and then a bunch of
stuff happens downstream of that
including a general inflammatory
response
part of which is cytokine release and
then you know
you get inflamed you start producing
snot uh the histamine itself sensitizes
nerve cells which is why things feel
itchy like um
a
stimulus that otherwise you wouldn't
even register you wouldn't even feel is
kind of elevated to the point that you
do sense it but you only sense it a
little bit so it's a tickle um so yeah
all of that stuff happens downstream of
histamine release and it seems that
spirulina
uh blocks histamine release and that's a
very cool and useful mechanism of action
because that means at least
theoretically it should work
synergistically with like antihistamine
medications so i am currently taking
both spirulina and loratidine which
is that is that allegra i don't know
whatever i just buy the might be
claritin claritin who cares i i just buy
the generics um but yeah so i i take
laradidine every allergy season um
and yeah the way that uh antihistamines
tend to work antihistamine medication
is they don't block histamine release
what they do is uh something called
competitive inhibition of the histamine
receptor so if you haven't taken biology
classes or if you haven't taken biology
in a while what competitive inhibition
is is basically you have a molecule that
binds to the same receptor as some other
target molecule
so that's the competitive part the
inhibition part is when it binds to that
receptor it doesn't have an effect so
basically you have
histamine receptors all over the place
when histamine binds to those receptors
that kind of causes an inflammatory
response downstream to that binding so
antihistamines go in they bind to those
same receptors don't let histamine latch
onto those receptors but when the
antihistamines bind to the histamine
receptor it doesn't cause the same
downstream inflammatory response that
histamines would um so if spirulina
actually
blocks some degree of histamine release
that shouldn't have any impact on the
efficacy
of antihistamine medications so they
work via different mechanisms of action
so theoretically they should have
synergistic effects instead of
competitive effects or effects that
might cancel each other out in theory
since they work via different mechanisms
of action if you take both maybe it
would be more effective than just taking
one or the other and in fact that is
what i do
and as i mentioned this is something
that i wish i remembered at the start of
every allergy season because if you
remember
maybe like three or four episodes ago i
was [ __ ] dying man um
like my my allergy symptoms were
were rough and at that point i was
already taking uh
more loratidine than it is probably
advisable for humans to take on a daily
basis and
i was in better shape than i would have
been had i not been taking the
loratadine but like i was still in
pretty bad shape and at this point
allergy season is much worse than it was
then like you walk outside now and
everything like it
raleigh looks like a hollywood movie uh
shooting in a location that's supposed
to be mexico you know how like uh in
movies when there's a scene in mexico
they just make everything yellow like
they give it a yellowy orange hue so
like dude outside looks like that right
now there's just a yellow blanket of
pollen on everything um
and like i'm still a little sniffly but
overall i'm doing fine uh and that is
because about two weeks ago i remembered
to start taking spirulina again
um
and also uh a shout out to curtis frank
who
i i actually don't know what curtis is
up to these days but uh one of the
founding members of examine.com uh he
recommended spirulina to me back in the
day
and i thought it seemed kind of silly as
a man who has dealt with
tremendous allergy issues my entire life
including like when i started getting
allergy shots the first
kind of round of it like if you've ever
gone through allergy shots you know this
if not
the way it works is basically
um you know it works kind of like a
vaccine like they introduce like little
bits of allergen into your system so you
have some amount of response to it but
basically like your immune system gets
used to the allergen over time so it
doesn't mount
as large of a response as it otherwise
would and the more allergic you are to
things the smaller dose they have to
start with but the more frequent the
shots
need to be to begin with um
and so i think generally they start
people off with like either one or three
shots per week when i started getting
allergy shots i had to go in literally
every weekday to get like just a
a little jab of allergen
to start the process of the allergy
shots um see i i've had a lot of medical
treatment for allergies and as i
mentioned like when i'm entering the
antihistamine game i'm entering it in a
big way uh like the the 10 milligram
pills where you're supposed to take one
don't don't take dosing advice for
antihistamines for me but i take like
four or five a day um like generally
three in the morning two at night and
that's just like the baseline i need to
function even after allergy shots so
when curtis was just like ah like
spirulina seems to be pretty good for
allergic rhinitis i was like yeah that
seems like [ __ ] to me if all of
this like legit medicine which which to
be clear does help me a lot like if
all of that has gotten me to the point
that i can just barely function during
allergy season there's no way that
taking like an algae supplement is
really gonna move the needle that much
but lo and behold that [ __ ] was
right uh i started taking spirulina and
it did have like a pretty marked impact
for me just kind of n equals one uh
again in conjunction with with other
antihistamines um
and so yeah like i would i would love to
see
more research on spirulina like it is
kind of shocking or not shocking but
striking
that you know tons of people have
seasonal allergy symptoms there are two
studies that seem to show that spirulina
works really really well for addressing
that um that just that just seems like
something that i would think other
researchers would look at and be like oh
like this is a really cool thing doesn't
seem like studies that would be all that
hard to do like basically you recruit
some people you give some of them pills
you give some of them placebo pills
come back three
three weeks a month later whatever and
just say like yeah hey are you less
sniffly than before maybe do a blood
draw to look at cytokine response seems
like a very useful study and a pretty
easy study to do um so i'm kind of
surprised there's not more research i
wish there was uh it would
like
i i feel like i haven't been as reserved
in this recommendation as i probably
should have been and part of that is
just because my n equals one experience
with it is so positive um
but yeah like from a purely objective
point of view some some degree of
skepticism is still warranted because
again we're dealing with a very small
body of research um
it would definitely be good to see
more work in this area
but the the mechanism of action makes
sense the research that does exist seems
to be pretty positive
my own experience with it is extremely
positive um
so yeah i mean if if you
also deal with really bad nasal allergy
symptoms during allergy season um
it doesn't seem like there's
really any meaningful risk associated
with supplementing with spirulina um
it's cheap like it's not gonna break the
bank to try and so uh
yeah it's
are there any uh potential drug
interactions with
uh common over-the-counter
uh allergy
medications
i mean not that i'm aware of but i'm
also not a pharmacist yeah
it might be worth looking into if you're
exploring this as an option yeah i i'm i
haven't heard anything about it but you
know it's kind of a standard caveat yeah
i mean
ask ask a doctor or pharmacist if like
if you're concerned about starting any
new supplement um ask a doctor or
pharmacist like hey i currently take
these drugs i want to try this
supplement uh can can you look it up in
in
whatever that resources that pharmacists
have like could this be bad um so yeah
that you know you might want to ask
about that but um
you know if if you want to if you want
to try something else uh
spirulina seems to be
pretty good stuff pretty cheap um might
have some some beneficial effects uh
separate from allergic rhinitis like
there there are a couple studies
suggesting that it might
uh imp lead lead to slight enhancements
in vo2 max following aerobic training
complete compared to placebo although
i'm not sure what the mechanism of
action is for that
uh
but yeah it's it's uh in my opinion
pretty good stuff
cool i i might give that a try i'm gonna
look into that after the show because i
i've been struggling a little bit uh you
know given the allergy situation around
here um but cool moving on we've got uh
quite a few questions from listeners
that we'd like to answer today
uh i'm going to kick things off i've got
a question from nicole
nicole
says that she often sees people
including registered dietitians claiming
that dietary fat
is very filling basically that has
a major impact on satiety
and that you should include dietary fat
in meals for these satiety benefits
however nicole was looking into it she
sees a few mechanistic things but you
know not a lot of really strong evidence
suggesting that
fat has a satiety inducing effect that
would actually yield the type of
outcomes you might be looking for a lot
of times when you're adding something to
a meal to increase satiety you're hoping
that it might reduce your co your
caloric intake at that meal or maybe at
subsequent meals in the the hours
following
so basically nicole is asking
what's the deal with fat and satiety um
and there is a really nice book chapter
that's available online
it's like one of those book chapters
that is open access and indexed in
pubmed so i'm going to put a link to
that book chapter in the show notes
but the book chapter basically tries to
address this very same question is
dietary fat satiating
and i think they do a great job
summarizing the research really
concisely but but still giving some good
practical takeaways
and what they conclude in the uh the
book chapter here based on the research
available is
yes in a controlled environment in uh
you know more mechanistically oriented
studies you can make a connection
between dietary fat and satiety
and the links there are you know having
more fat in the meal
has certain impacts on satiety related
hormone release
it can
delay
you know it can kind of
prolong the digestion time of the meal
so that it kind of delays that gastric
emptying rate so there are mechanistic
reasons to believe
that adding some fat to uh to a meal
could
theoretically increase satiety during
that meal or or immediately following
that meal
but they dig into the the details within
this book chapter and they highlight the
fact that
certain types of fat are more satiating
than others um you know that that's kind
of one of the common things we like to
do when we talk about dietary fat is
treat it like it's just one thing
um and
obviously you can take dietary fat and
you can separate that out into saturated
or unsaturated and then you can separate
that even further with polyunsaturated
versus monounsaturated but you can dig
even deeper and look at the specific
fatty acid composition of a particular
dietary fat source so
not all saturated fat is exactly the
same thing there are different saturated
fatty acids that make up you know the
dietary sources of saturated fat that we
consume
so
uh there's a lot more to it than just
add some fat to the diet and reap the
benefits of more satiety and when you
start looking at free living conditions
so people that are out there putting
together meals in the real world
things get a lot more complicated it's
not just adding some fat and hoping you
chose the right type of fat uh you know
there are a lot of other factors to
consider and in my opinion you know you
you can break it down into
differences between individuals you know
they they mention in this chapter that
there are there appear to be a couple of
phenotypes where some people are more
susceptible to
uh over feeding when exposed to a high
fat diet than others you know there are
differing responses to the addition of
fat to a diet some people
you know are are much more susceptible
to fat gain on a high fat diet than
others so there's those inter-individual
differences um where there are genetic
components behavioral components
psychological components uh but i think
probably the biggest thing to consider
if you're trying to use the addition of
fat
as a strategy to promote satiety
is now we have to consider the
palatability of a meal
and a lot of times you know when people
demonize high-fat foods
a lot of times
if you ask them well what do you mean by
a high-fat food what they're really
talking about are calorically dense
foods that tend to be highly highly
palatable these are foods that are very
enjoyable to eat and they evoke uh quite
a
pronounced
reward response when it comes to kind of
the hedonic regulation of food intake so
it's not we're not just talking about
dietary fat we're talking about
something like ice cream right where
there's plenty of fat there's also
plenty of carbohydrate uh the the
texture is great the mouth feel is great
the flavor is great so it's not just hey
what happens when you put fat in the
diet it's what happens when you
introduce
palatable foods that contain fat into
the diet and so a lot of times you know
you can talk all you want about
physiological satiety and different
satiety related hormones and digest
digestion rates and rates of gastric
emptying that stuff is all fine in a
laboratory setting but if the actual
application of this you know if
someone's seeking out more fat and
they're gravitating toward these really
enjoyable
highly palatable foods that might
provoke some over consumption then you
have not just lost the potential benefit
of higher satiety but you've probably
actually gone the other direction and
introduced even more caloric intake into
the equation um just because the the
hedonic system regulating food intake is
so susceptible to these palatable kind
of rewarding foods that when we eat them
they make us feel great so
i think you know
i personally when someone says hey
should i eat more fat to have more
satiety my gut like my first response is
probably not because um
i i don't think we would see at the
population level if the guidance out
there was hey eat more fat it'll fill
you up i am very very skeptical that
that would you know induce a reduction
in body weight on a population level and
even at the individual level
you know the idea of increasing fat as a
dietary strategy
is uh it's a very vague thing you know
there are many different ways to
implement that type of advice that would
take many different forms and have many
different potential outcomes so my
general approach when it comes to eating
for satiety is i think in most cases we
are asking the wrong questions
a lot of times you'll you'll hear people
kind of pitting
one macronutrient against the other and
saying should i have more carbs or more
fat i'm trying to increase satiety i
think we
focus too much on macronutrient
composition and we're missing really
important things we can do to increase
uh the satiety we experience during and
following a meal so rather than focusing
on macronutrients exclusively
this is a topic i've been writing about
a lot in mass over the last couple years
and i've kind of put together a list of
strategies that i give my clients when
they're struggling with hunger and
satiety so uh you know a lot of times
i'll tell people try to eat more slowly
there's really fascinating research on
that where there are different
strategies to induce slower eating
you know so you could opt for uh foods
that just have harder texture um you you
simply have to chew more and it can slow
down your eating rate um i i saw one
really creative study where
we were talking about this before
recording today but
uh you know obviously there's a lot of
research showing that if you eat an
apple
versus uh drinking an iso caloric amount
of apple juice uh it's probably not
surprising that apple
you know produces greater satiety than
an equivalent amount of apple juice but
what was really interesting was there
was a study where they had people eating
apple juice as if it was a soup so just
like spooning it
and just the fact that using the spoon
and going spoonful by spoonful and
slowing down a little bit that actually
restored a pretty substantial amount of
the satiety that you would observe with
just eating an apple um so slowing your
meals down in whatever form that takes
can be really helpful and there's
there's a few theories about why that
might be
so
some people you'll most commonly hear
people talk about just the
the time course of releasing satiety
inducing hormones over the course of a
meal that could be contributing you're
just giving those satiety hormones an
opportunity to uh you know become
released and do their thing after the
initiation of a meal
there's also been research looking at
just the uh the sensory experience of
the meal if you're eating more slowly
you are experiencing more of the flavor
more of the aroma of the meal per
calorie because you're just extending
that out and kind of savoring each bite
rather why are you smiling because
because i don't taste no
i i was smiling because
that's incredibly true yeah um
i i am a notoriously fast eater uh also
someone who has notoriously had issues
with body weight who knows those two
things might be related but i'm also
very into cooking and i like making good
things and when i when i make a new dish
here here is my eating process the first
bite i take
i i will chew on it and try to
experience the full depth of flavor like
just to make sure i did a good job and
from the time that bite goes into my
mouth to when i swallow the first bite
is probably like 30 to 45 seconds the
amount of time it takes to eat the rest
of the serving is probably an additional
30 to 45 seconds yeah but so like i know
that if i want to if i make something
really good and i want to fully
experience and enjoy it or just check my
work make sure it's good that i should
eat slowly um because like that's what i
do when i'm actually assessing is this
as good as i think it is but the entire
rest of the meal i'm like nah [ __ ] it
like we're we're speed running dinner
yeah yeah um so you know it that that uh
sensory experience of the meal could be
a contributing mechanism for how slower
eating does seem to pretty consistently
uh reduce ad libitum calorie intake at a
meal within laboratory conditions
um
there's also uh so i mentioned
the sensory experience
i mentioned the uh the satiety hormones
in the timeline there the other thing
people have been looking into is more of
the kind of
psychological or the more of the
cognitive
aspects of eating the meal so they
wonder if having more attention on the
meal
uh allows you to kind of really solidify
the memory of like i spent some time and
attention on eating this meal and in the
hours that follow
you because you are more kind of
mentally present and cognitively present
as you were consuming that meal perhaps
there's a memory related mechanism that
leads to less snacking and less
overeating in subsequent hours after
that meal uh so there's been a lot of
research into exactly what's going on
with slow eating
but it seems like a pretty consistent
positive benefit if you are trying to
enhance satiety to a meal it's just
slowing down a little bit
other tips i usually give people
aside from eating more slowly would be
avoiding really hyper palatable meals
while you're dieting structuring your
meals with plenty of protein plenty of
fiber plenty of water content and when
you do that when you have high protein
high fiber high water content you're
usually going to find that the energy
density of the meal tends to be pretty
low
and then just including plenty of
unprocessed or minimally processed foods
which again if you're including a lot of
unprocessed or minimally processed foods
you're more likely to include plenty of
foods with lower energy density and with
harder texture
and that's not a hard and fast rule you
can find exceptions to that but if you
are constructing a diet that has a lot
of unprocessed food uh or minimally
processed um
and what you're gonna find is a lot of
items in there with low energy density
and harder texture so you're gonna be
chewing more it's going to be more bites
per meal it's going to slow down the
rate of eating so
there are a lot of things we can focus
on if we're trying to increase satiety
those are the ones that i focus on when
it comes to just what you're putting on
your plate
but one other thing i encourage people
to consider is adopting more of an
acceptance based approach to hunger so
if you're
embarking on a weight loss diet
or you're trying to maintain a reduced
body weight you kind of know going into
that that hunger might be an issue it
might be something that you are going to
experience
and
you know have to work through and so
there's really two ways to approach that
if you want to kind of dichotomize it
one would be i am waging war on hunger
and i need to fight this every step of
the way
it is a rejection of hunger it is kind
of classifying and internalizing hunger
as being an objectively negative thing
that you must fight against
and hopefully overcome and kind of
defeat
but if you adopt a more acceptance based
approach
it's just a shift in mindset
and there's some interesting research
showing this to be a pretty effective
strategy when it comes to
experiencing hunger in the context of
dieting
but the idea is that you are accepting
hunger as part of the process now it
doesn't mean you're gonna
be excited about it and enjoy hunger
when it's happening but it's a
completely different mindset where
you're focused on uh acknowledging that
hunger experiencing it not forcing it to
go away not you know waging war on that
hunger but just kind of accepting that
as part of the process and trying to
reframe that and
if you dig into it and you take this
acceptance focused approach to hunger uh
you can find yourself almost looking for
a bit of a silver lining there right so
if you are dieting and you notice some
hunger the first thing you can recognize
is okay this is present and i know that
it's not permanent you know it's going
to come and go when i eat and fast and
you know
periods between meals it'll come and go
uh so it's not permanent it's not going
to be here forever it's not something
that necessarily requires immediate
action
and it also could potentially be
indicative of the fact that i'm
generally on the right track here you
know i'm in an energy deficit and hunger
is one clue
that here i am you know eating a lower
calorie intake which is compatible with
my goal whether it's weight loss or
maintenance of a reduced body weight uh
so i it's it's not that i'm saying
you know the initial question was about
you know fat and satiety it's not that
i'm saying you know there's nothing we
can do about satiety because i think
there are a lot of things when it comes
to satiety and hunger that we can focus
on which can be quite helpful whether it
comes to
how we construct a meal or how we view
hunger and satiety in general
but a lot of times the question does end
up being
fat versus carbs go or is protein
actually satiating and i think those are
i understand where the questions come
from but i think if we dig deeper we can
ask more nuanced questions
and when we do that we get answers that
are very practical very actionable and a
lot more helpful than just focusing on
macronutrient breakdown
yeah that all makes a lot of sense to me
i i have three things to add and i hope
i remember all of them
but the first one is regarding uh
acceptance-based approaches to hunger
it occurred this occurred to me
uh the other day maybe like two or three
days ago
chatting with someone in either the
macro factor stronger by science
facebook group
i can't remember which one but it was
one of the two um
and it occurred to me uh talking about
this
that i think a lot of us
just implicitly adopt an
acceptance-based approach to unpleasant
sensations during exercise um
and like maybe we didn't even have to
consciously do it like maybe a lot of
people who stick with exercise
were people who were just like innately
wired this way but like a lot of the the
sensations that you experience with
resistance training
if you if you zoomed out like you would
probably classify them as objectively
unpleasant like the the burning
sensation in your muscles near the end
of a set um the the doms you feel after
a hard workout maybe like joint
creakiness you get um
if you
decontextualize that from lifting and
you know you're just
chilling going about your day and then
your body suddenly started feeling the
way it does after a really hard workout
you wouldn't say hell yeah i [ __ ]
love this you would say i'm dying
there's something
horribly wrong with me like those those
are decoupled from resistance training
unpleasant sensations but
um
you know i i do think we tend to grow to
like them
because we do view them
as at least to some degree like proxies
for i've worked hard enough to present
an adequate stimulation stimulus for
adaptation uh the dom's like uh you know
what i know as a science person doms
isn't a particularly uh valid predictor
of hypertrophic responses but still in
my lizard brain i think it is you know
if nothing else it tells me like yeah i
worked pretty hard yesterday um
so you know you do come to
either like you just enjoy that from the
jump because you have a slight
masochistic streak or you come to
enjoy and appreciate or at least like
fully tolerate those things over time um
and i think that uh
i don't see why hunger can't be
a very similar thing like it it is an
unpleasant experience uh but like you
said it is
if you're trying to lose weight it is
also an indicator that you're probably
on the right track um so i think that
that little that little shift in
thinking like in comparing it to the
sensations you feel from exercise uh
might be helpful
uh and if i could add one a little bit
of additional clarification there uh you
might hear this conversation and say oh
cool so i should seek to be very very
hungry during a diet that's not the
implication here oh yeah yeah for sure
um you know and i've even heard of
people who kind of
use almost like an intuitive eating
slash auto regulation approach to
dieting i think i heard uh
gabrielle gabrielle fundero talking
about this dr fundero
but kind of auto
your hunger to like a particular level
out of 10 during a diet if you don't
want to do tracking you know as a way
you know to kind of say okay i'm
restricting enough to induce mild hunger
and if it gets too extreme then maybe i
need to adjust some things and if i'm
experiencing no hunger and weight's not
moving then that tells me something
so it's it's not that we're seeking out
hunger for its own sake it's just that
if we are doing the things that are
compatible with our weight reduction
goal we're probably gonna run into it
and we shouldn't necessarily uh
consider that to be a negative thing
yeah yeah for sure um so yeah that was
the first thing i wanted to say just
that that analogy with exercise might be
helpful for some people uh second thing
i wanted to say is one of the first
things you mentioned
was that the satiety response that
people get from various macronutrients
um
might might vary considerably between
individuals i absolutely think that's
correct uh because
like i i've seen so many times over the
years people saying like oh fat is
highly satiating uh people saying like i
went on keto and it changed my life like
it completely blunted my appetite when
you look at the research on keto there
there seems to be some suggestions of
that that it uh on average blunts hunger
that was not my experience like we've
talked about this before i did keto back
in the day um
i mean i went when i
uh
like i i still felt like i had to
restrict to some degree when i was doing
keto and like even now like if i am
going to overeat it's always on high fat
stuff um and it is like generally highly
palatable high fat stuff
and like i i just don't get that satiety
response that people
say you're supposed to get um like i i
could go into a steakhouse just look at
the biggest steak on the menu if they've
got something that's like 24 30 ounces
uh
i don't order it but in my younger days
i used to um and yeah like two hours
later i'd be like ah yeah i'm ready to
eat again um
so
i don't for me personally the
the uh
i guess fact that fat tends to be
satiating for people uh didn't resonate
with me personally um
and yeah like i think the key there is
you know we're dealing with averages
there is a lot of variation between
individuals
and it's not
it's not incompatible to say
fat on average seems to be fairly
satiating and
fat is not particularly satiating for me
as an individual both of those things
can be true
uh and that's something worth keeping in
mind and then if i could add one thing
to that it's interesting because uh
even among just the two of us here
we have that variability present because
i did a ketogenic diet for an extended
period of time it's probably six seven
eight months something like that
uh and i found it to be remarkably
satiating i i did have spontaneous
weight loss without
conscious restriction uh just because
the the high fat you know decent amount
of protein but to me what was
interesting about it was it was high fat
without
a lot of the really palatable fat
sources that would typically induce me
to overeat
because usually those would have enough
carbohydrate that i couldn't really work
them in yeah so uh but yeah like it i
could eat the same amount of fat as when
i was on a ketogenic diet but if it was
coming from sources that weren't
uh
you know restrictive in terms of carb
source uh i probably would not have had
the same experience like i i can't just
increase my fat and watch my weight drop
it has to be fat with carb restriction
because now i'm not getting those really
hyper palatable fat sources for me dude
i i was not eating hyper palatable stuff
uh i was i was in college at the time i
was
dirt poor yeah and so
most of my calories were either coming
from
like skin on chicken thighs that i added
extra fat to or from the the 73 27
ground beef yeah that
at the time uh you could get a 10 pound
sleeve of from walmart for a buck 50 a
pound yeah incredible um but yeah like
you would you would basically have to
make like really thin patties and sear
it really quick just because like dude
73-27 that's so much fat yeah and so if
you made like large-ish burger patties
and cooked them
well done all the way through just like
one
four ounce patty would just be swimming
in a pool of of beef fat by the end it
was by the end of the time it was done
cooking so like you had you had to cook
things in particular ways to make sure
that like it held on to enough fat so
like dude that was the basis of of my my
keto phase
and uh yeah it wasn't particularly good
but i still didn't spontaneously lose
weight yeah um
let's see and then the last thing i
wanted to say
um
not really adding anything but just just
reiterating
um
i do think that especially among like
kind of sciency people there is a
um an impulse to maybe be overly
reductive uh because like that seems to
comport well with scientific thinking
where
you know the the more things you can
control for
the the better you can
you know make sure that the effect
you're picking up is the actual effect
you're trying to measure and it's not
being influenced by outside things and
the better you can get at the underlying
mechanisms behind what you end up
wanting to study
but
also with translational research you
know you're going from just kind of
basic science food science stuff to
okay now what are you actually
recommending people to eat um
if it if what you're studying gets so
abstracted from what people actually
consume in the real world the research
can begin to lose some of its
translational value and end up becoming
too reductive
because like ultimately people aren't
eating protein carbs fat people are
eating food and those nutrients are
coming in the context of food
and so like if you find
you know that when you isolate fat and
carbohydrate if like one or the other is
more satiating but then you actually get
into the real world and you know maybe
just like
a powdered maltodextrin has one effect
on satiety but when you like you
mentioned water content and fiber
content when you put that carbohydrate
in the context of fruit that you're
consuming or like whole grain bread or
something like that you know maybe the
carbohydrate content is matched but the
satiety response you get from it could
be very different because
it's not just the carbohydrates you're
eating it's everything else in all of
the foods you're consuming that you're
eating as well
and and all of those things can have an
impact so i i think that
it is easy to
not necessarily forget that but attempt
to overlook that uh in
in the hopes of being kind of more
objective and sciencey but when you take
that too far
you can just end up
um
you know basing your recommendations for
the real world
on research that is so far abstracted
from the real world that it
uh that it loses some of its
translational value
yeah and that reminds me of uh an
article i did for mass years ago at this
point but the question was is protein
satiating what was kind of the focus of
the article
and i mentioned in the article like it
was kind of like a meta-analysis i think
and results were kind of inconsistent
and it was one of those situations where
the answer was not or the question
wasn't
why are there inconsistencies but like
how could there not be inconsistencies
because like a
protein intervention within that context
could be
a whey protein shake it could be a
yogurt product it could be a bar
it could be a piece of meat uh and they
have such different characteristics as
food items that to think that they all
represent
uh the same generalizable satiety
response would be
really difficult to justify if you zoom
out a little bit and so
we we like to reduce it to very simple
questions and very simple answers with
very simple elements uh but sometimes
that's you know not the best way to do
it like you mentioned
um all right so we are running
extremely long with this episode we're
at about 50 minutes already um i do want
to answer really a really quick question
about supplementation if you want to
pick out one that you can answer
relatively concisely i think that would
wrap up the show so i'll start
and you can kind of dig through your
list of questions and see if there's one
that jumps out to you
i got a question from reed
and reed
basically said they'd be interested in a
discussion between me
and barbell medicine regarding
supplementation
according to reed barbell medicine has
been fairly outspoken against uh most
supplementation in uh parentheses it
says fish oil multivitamins vitamin d
etc the only exceptions that come to
mind are creatine beta alanine
citrulline malate
essential amino acids and beetroot so
i'm i haven't like fact checked that i'm
going to accept that that is a uh an
accurate representation of their
position
i like the guys
i like the team at barbell medicine i
like the content they put out i think
they've done a lot of good when it comes
to uh breaking people of
a lot of the fear-mongering regarding
exercise and movement and pain
um i i really like what they do and i
think they do really nice work over
there um
if this is a you know i i don't consume
much content in the fitness space so i i
didn't like dig in and do a lot of fact
checking but i'll just kind of answer
this vaguely like
what uh what do you think about people
who say
that you know multivitamins vitamin d
and fish oil are unnecessary
overrated
etc so
i think
if i were to sit down with someone who
advises against supplementation with
those three categories fish oil
multivitamin vitamin d
we would probably agree on the best case
scenarios
so the best case scenarios would be
either you get all the nutrition you
need from food you've got a
well-balanced diet with a variety of
different food sources that is a totally
complete diet that covers all your needs
that's obviously best case scenario
no no multivitamin needed and you're
good to go
the next best scenario would be that if
you have any concerns related to
insufficient nutrient intake or
insufficient nutrient status
you would
visit a qualified health care
professionals and and they would order
the appropriate testing they would
identify any deficiencies or
insufficiencies and then they would
prescribe a targeted supplementation
program that is followed up with serial
blood testing to make sure that
the inadequacy or insufficiency is
rectified um
now
that's you know best case scenario but
i think
practically speaking sometimes we
diverge from that right so in the real
world sometimes you run into situations
where
there's an individual who is
not diligently tracking their
micronutrient intake they must not use
macro factor because we've got all the
micronutrient coverage that you need but
you know they're not paying attention
very closely to their mac or to their
micronutrient intake they're not paying
attention to okay the vitamin c that i'm
taking in am i cooking it in a way that
it's leaching out and i'm not actually
consuming it you know there's issues of
cooking method preparation method um
anti-nutrients aren't scary but they do
exist you know sometimes you do have to
consider combinations of nutrients
consumed at the same meal so some people
just don't want to deal with looking
into all that
and and so for people like that it's
really difficult to say well okay
go and see a physician
fight your way through the u.s health
care system get that testing done do
serial visits back to get more checking
done
that's great if you're willing to do it
i haven't been to a doctor in like 10
years that's not a recommendation but i
think for a lot of people they look at
it and they say
okay i'm not really 10 years was an
exaggeration now that i think about it
but i try to interact with the medical
system as infrequently as possible
um
in america that's just the way it goes i
think but uh you're playing russian
roulette like either you're
uh
like either your insurance company is
going to come through surprisingly well
and you know you wind up with like a 200
bill or you know you you go in for a
checkup you get referred out for like
one visit with a specialist and boom
you're bankrupted right and
who knows
it's gonna go one of those two routes
generally it's going the first route but
the chance of it going the second route
is a little bit higher than i find
acceptable yeah and and just to like
this is a real story i i the last time i
went to the doctor i needed some imaging
done
and i i talked to the first person who
like referred me to the next person and
the next person every step of the way
between my initial visit and the person
doing the actual imaging like
every single step of the way i said can
you tell me how much this will cost
and of course they said absolutely not
and i said no i just need to know
how many zeros
are we talking about a hundred dollars
or are we talking about ten thousand and
they said honestly i have no idea
and that was all the way until you've
already done it and there's no going
back and they'll say someone will tell
you in two months whether this was a
hundred dollars or ten thousand uh
good luck yeah so anyway that was a bit
of a tangent but so there's a lot of
people who are like listen i don't want
to go through all the effort to look at
all these different micronutrients
i don't want to go through the effort of
going to a doctor like six times to get
any insufficiencies corrected and it's
not that i am concerned about overt like
serious nutrient deficiencies like i
don't think i have scurvy at the moment
but i do wonder if maybe my diet is a
little bit insufficient to the extent
that maybe i'm experiencing more fatigue
than i ought to maybe i'm not feeling my
best maybe i'm not performing my best
and like i'm not into the whole
biohacking idea where you just convince
everybody that they're like a shell of
what they could be and they need to like
go through some complicated sequence of
supplementation trials to figure out how
to feel good uh but i i do suspect that
there is some
area in the middle there where it's like
there's the intake required to like not
have an extremely deleterious nutrient
deficiency
and then there's optimal and there's
somewhere in between like i don't think
the sole purpose of micronutrient intake
is just to not have
severely grave deficiencies with
clinically obvious consequences so if
you're someone who's like listen i want
to make sure i've got my bases covered i
want to be in line with adequate intakes
i think i might be a little bit low on
some of these but i don't want to go
through the process of visiting a doctor
six times
i don't think it's that crazy to say you
know what maybe you do take a
multivitamin and maybe if you live you
know depending on the latitude depending
on how often you get outside depending
on the the season you know maybe you
just are not getting any sun exposure so
yeah maybe a low dose of vitamin d makes
sense uh you know epa and dha like a
fish oil supplement maybe you don't eat
any fatty fish at all
and there's research suggesting that
certain tissues it makes sense to have
some epa and dha in those cell membranes
maybe you say you know what maybe i do
want to get into some of those
recommended levels of like averaging
maybe 300 500 milligrams per day of
combined epa and dha so not like the
super high levels you see you know some
supplement trials they'll do like six
grams a day of fish oil maybe we're
talking about one gram a day of fish oil
uh i i think they're
i think it's pretty
justifiable to to say maybe in some of
those situations it makes sense to say
instead of going through the really
tedious process maybe i'll take a
multivitamin maybe i'll try some fish
oil supplementation
and i know a lot of times when you
mention this people push back and say
well i mean i live in the united states
you know it's an affluent country there
is uh you know
the the food supply is generally
abundant compared to other countries
no one in america has nutrient
deficiencies like i've heard people make
that claim and that's just fully
incompatible with all the evidence yeah
there's a difference between no one has
nutrient deficiencies and no one is
dying of berry berry anymore yeah so i i
think that people like i i
or at least insufficiencies yeah i mean
i i see people say that all the time
where they're like oh dude like
you go to the grocery store for your
food you don't you're not experiencing
food insecurity there's no way that you
have inadequate intake of a
micronutrient and like
that's just not true brother i don't eat
vegetables
but like uh yeah i mean if you look at
some of the research you'll see like
estimates that 31
of the us population is at risk of
having at least one vitamin deficiency
or anemia uh you'll see um you know
studies where they'll look at um you
know there's one study where they
compared people who take multivitamins
to people who don't and taking a
multivitamin was associated with a lower
prevalence of inadequacy for 15 out of
the 17 micronutrients that were examined
like if you look at the research
there is evidence that there are people
uh in
affluent countries who are not meeting
adequate intakes for micronutrients
and they are not
experienced like it's not like there's
you know
you know there is
the possibility that you have inadequate
nutrient intakes without having scurvy
without having rickets you know like it
doesn't always take this like
catastrophic medical condition
to uh to tell you hey by the way you're
a little bit low on your vitamin c or
your vitamin d
there are a lot of people in the united
states purely based on the data who are
experiencing subclinical
uh insufficiencies related to either uh
circulating levels of micronutrients or
actual intakes of nutrients uh and those
can very easily be rectified with uh
with supplementation strategies that are
very
cost effective have an extremely good
safety profile and do have the potential
for some benefit
another
thing i often see when people push back
against this is they'll be like dude
vitamins are useless and they'll send me
a study and it'll be like a big
randomized controlled trial and they'll
say like
people with uh people taking
multivitamins didn't live longer i'm
like
yeah i didn't think you were gonna die
yeah from from not taking a multivitamin
it's a matter of like are you hitting
these these benchmarks for adequate
intake and if not
might you have a better subjective
experience day to day and be in a
generally healthier place if you were
hitting those benchmarks for adequate
intake yeah i i've seen that as well
with uh with vitamin d like a a couple
people have hit me up on instagram uh
saying like hey eric has talked about uh
vitamin d supplementation on the podcast
before
new study just came out turns out that
supplementing with vitamin d doesn't
improve strength hypertrophy outcomes
i'm like
that's really cool
but did you know that vitamin d
interacts with more things in your body
than your musculoskeletal system
that uh
may be relevant
yeah so um so yeah that that's really
just the
the the root of any disagreement like uh
you know sometimes and it's important to
recognize like if you say i don't think
i need a multivitamin i don't think i
need vitamin d i don't think i need fish
oil like
it's very unlikely that you're going to
experience
a clinically relevant negative
consequence of not taking any of these
supplements like i don't consider them
to be essential
but for people who are not being mindful
of their intakes of these nutrients and
are not getting sun exposure i do
recommend in many cases very
conservative supplementation
approaches which might be as simple as a
multivitamin and just enough fish oil to
get you close to what
what experts say is
an advisable intake of fish oil so i
don't think you're going to really make
or break your health or your uh
performance or your training adaptations
by using any of these categories of
supplements but i do view them as
supplements that aside from some very
specific instances
generally have terrific safety profiles
and generally are quite affordable uh
like my multivitamin is four cents a day
uh vitamin d is way cheaper than that so
like we're talking about making in some
cases like a six cent per day investment
um and
yeah
an investment that like i said uh
barring a few very specific instances uh
you know the safety profile looks looks
terrific like i have seen some instances
where
people have issues with vitamin d just
because the supplement was formulated
poorly and it was giving them like a
hundred times the dose than was on the
label obviously that's not a good thing
fish oil
can can have some impacts on the way
that your blood clots and so in certain
medical situations that can be
unfavorable but
again you know that that i don't think
that's grounds for saying that generally
all fish oil should be avoided
um and then uh
there have been some studies indicating
that certain vitamins
might be bad when it comes to cancer
outcomes specifically for smokers
my understanding is that those findings
are a bit inconsistent they're kind of
hit or miss
and there's there's also not i don't
think they've identified a clear
mechanism describing why that would be
and of course in that scenario
the
driver you know the carcinogenic agent
there that is driving that relationship
is smoking status yeah just just to flip
a recommendation we gave on the last
podcast uh this time around the stronger
by science podcast is coming out against
smoking yeah so like i i don't think it
makes sense to
construct broad supplementation
guidelines based on the assumption that
everyone hearing it is a smoker you know
so like
yeah i if if i were a smoker and i was
thinking about vitamin supplementation
you know i'd talk to my doctor figure it
out um but but general recommendation i
i think um you know that that's kind of
a special population yeah personally so
that that's my view on supplementing
with those types of things and uh i like
i said i don't think it's the type of
thing that's gonna you know
i don't expect people to call me up in
30 years and say ah man i ignored your
revi your advice and boy do i regret it
like i i don't think it's a night or day
difference for your performance your
recovery your health um but i don't see
tremendous downsides to just covering
your bases and getting those adequate
intakes
yeah i think that's fair um the one
thing i'll add just to emphasize
something you said is
um
you know there there have
been formulation issues with
various supplement not just vitamin and
mineral supplements but just supplements
across the board um
and and so if someone did want to opt
for the very conservative recommendation
of saying like now i don't take vitamin
d don't take multivitamins um
on the basis that you know if you if
you're not going to assume that
everyone's going to do their research
and make sure what they're taking is is
good and well formulated then you know
maybe the benefits
are unlikely to be particularly large
and there there is at least some
non-trivial risk of really negative
outcomes if someone
ends up taking a supplement that's just
a really shitty supplement um
like i think that that's
an entirely fair and defensible position
um but i mean i think if you want to be
really conservative about it
there are sites like lab door and
there's another one i forget what it is
but there are sites that do maybe
consumer lab yeah yeah consumer lab i
think um that do
third party testing of various
supplements for purity and safety um so
yeah if you want to minimize your risk
of
you know having some something
catastrophically bad happening because
what was supposed to be in the
supplement wasn't in the supplement or
things that
things that weren't supposed to be in
the supplement were in the supplement um
you know look at look at third-party
testing sites like make sure what you're
taking is good um and i i personally
think that that should go a long way
towards towards mitigating risk yeah and
you know i don't argue every nutrition
topic with the same level of like
insistence where it's like no i need
everyone to take my side on this like i
know a lot of people are gonna listen to
this
uh and say i don't think i need these
supplements like i eat a pretty good
diet and it's important to reiterate
i think that's terrific like if you
don't the the best case scenario is that
you don't need to take a multivitamin
vitamin d or fish oil you've already got
your bases covered with your diet you
try it it doesn't do anything you stop
using it because you didn't need it in
the first place dude
that doesn't make me lose sleep i think
that's best case scenario nice
uh all right did you have one you wanted
to do yeah it's not on the outline but
this is a
so i want to respond to a
pres perspective and concern that i've
seen
uh three or four times within the past
week that is i think based on
a very
understandable bit of confusion
um
and that is the
the efficacy of bia scales for tracking
changes
in body composition over time
and so
this is a slightly different
conversation than the accuracy of bia
scales for assessing body composition in
the first place so um you know if you've
been uh hanging around the
evidence-based fitness space for a while
i'm sure you've encountered the
perspective backed by an enormous amount
of evidence that bia scales are
not particularly accurate when it comes
to assessing body composition those are
the scales that have
the the little like metal
are they electrodes i guess they are
they're passing a electrical current
through you yeah the ones with like the
little elect the little metal electrodes
on them uh where you stand on them
barefoot and they tell you not just your
weight but an estimate of your body fat
percentage um
they don't work well they don't uh
they don't
tell you
uh particularly accurately what your
body composition is and that's largely
just based on limitations of the
technology like if if you're only
running bia currents through your feet
um
really it's it's
roughly
assessing or estimating water content of
your legs and then using that
to kind of extrapolate body composition
of your legs and then based on uh how
much you weigh and also your sex they
then use that to extrapolate to
the composition of the rest of your body
you'll notice i just said extrapolate
three times there are a lot of
assumptions baked into that um
and
you know it's the the potential for
error is very large so you know i think
most people are
are aware of that who are listening to
this podcast but
you can go a level deeper uh
and say well you know there's a
difference between validity and role and
reliability um
so if something is valid it's it's going
to accurately re reflect reality so if
you're 20 body fat maybe it will tell
you that you're
somewhere between 18 and 22 body fat
like it gets you pretty close that's
validity and then reliability is
basically how repeatable a measurement
is so something can be invalid but also
highly reliable which in many cases is
just as good so if
you know if bia is consistently telling
you that your body fat percentage is
eight percent higher than it actually is
you're 15 but it says you're 23
but every time you step on the scale
when you're 15 it says you're 23
uh that is an invalid measurement it's
not telling you your actual body
composition but it is a reliable
measurement and oftentimes reliable
measurements even if they're invalid are
just as useful because the thinking goes
they can help you track changes over
time so if your bia scale
goes from saying you're 23 body fat to
20 body fat you know you're not 20 body
fat but you know that there's that eight
percent built-in error so it means
you're actually 12 body fat and so if
something is reliable but not valid it
can still be very useful but where i
think the disconnect is
is that
for for just test retest reliability bia
scales are pretty reliable so if you
step on your scale
uh you know tomorrow morning and then
you step off uh you don't eat or drink
anything you don't use the bathroom
again you step on the bia scale again
five minutes later it will probably tell
you that your body fat percentage is
very very similar to what it you it told
you it was five minutes prior
um
so you know that's that's a high degree
of same-day reliability and so
uh people look at that and they're like
oh so this is a reliable measure i don't
want to put too much stock in what the
actual number says but that means i can
use it to track changes over time
and that's where the disconnect is and
the biggest thing i want to point out is
there's a difference between same-day
reliability and reliability of tracking
over time so if you can establish that
for you today there's say a five percent
difference between what your bia scale
says and what a dexa scan says
you can't necessarily assume that that
relationship is going to persist
on an ongoing basis because
ultimately
the scale is still using bia and so the
um
the
limitations and assumptions of bia are
still built in
to the numbers it's giving you so for
example um
it's not uncommon to be using a bia
scale to
be in a calorie deficit to lose some
weight and you know maybe it's the start
of a diet you've lost five pounds six
pounds something like that and your bia
scale say it says oh hey like you've
only lost six pounds but guess what four
of those are muscle and then you say oh
[ __ ] that's bad i've barely lost any
weight i'm all i'm already just shedding
lean mass not losing much fat at all
this is going catastrophically bad and
that's based on the assumption that the
same day reliability of bia extrapolates
to
like reliably tracking changes over time
but the reason it's probably not going
to do that
is because of basically the way bia
works so
um
like muscle uh and
lean tissue in general tends to be
better hydrated than fat tissue is like
it has more water content uh and so
it's basically trying to pick up on
water content and use that to
extrapolate body composition
and so
let's say you start a diet you go into a
caloric deficit that's probably going to
come with a reduction in carbohydrate
intake uh you know and you lose a little
muscle glycogen
that decreases the the hydration of
muscle tissue bia is going to pick up on
that
as a
loss in lean mass and a smaller
reduction in fat mass than actually
happened
and so yeah it's going to say you lost a
lot of muscle you didn't actually lose a
lot of muscle you just lost some of the
water content in your muscles but bia
has no way of knowing that
and also
since a bia scale is just passing that
electro
electrical current through your legs it
can't know what's happening in your
upper body so
you know maybe
based on what it can see the body
composition of your legs looks about the
same
but maybe you're losing a ton of
abdominal fat or visceral fat or fat off
of your upper body there's literally no
way for your bia scale to know that
that's happening and it's just going to
look and say like well you know i'm
seeing about the same resistance to this
electrical current in the legs so uh it
doesn't seem like body comp is changing
all that much
you know maybe similar amounts of muscle
and fat is being lost that's not the
case uh but
the the technology itself has no way of
picking up on that um
so yeah like bia scales might be
might give you repeatable measurements
on the same day
but due to the limitations of the
technology it is probably not going to
reliably track changes in body comp over
time or tell you particularly reliably
how much fat versus muscle you're losing
uh in a deficit or how much fat versus
muscle you're gaining in a surplus same
day reliability and reliably tracking
changes over time
similar concepts different things bia
scales are pretty good at the former not
so much at the latter so
um yeah if if every indication is that
your diet is going well you know your
your performance in the gym seems to be
keeping up you don't visibly look in the
mirror like you're shedding a ton of
muscle but your scale says oh man you're
down six pounds but you've already lost
five pounds of muscle just ignore it it
it is
giving you a very rough estimation of
changes it is not measuring changes and
that's that's a very important
distinction
um so yeah i mean
i
i personally think that uh
body fat percentage estimates from bia
scales are
are
less than worthless um because if they
end up being
correct it's pretty much by chance and
if they end up tracking changes in body
composition uh reliably incorrectly
that's also more or less by chance um
like there
so i i don't think they
give you reliable enough correct
information to actually be useful but
there's a very high chance that they're
going to give you
information that
will mislead you about what's actually
going on so
you know you don't get anything
beneficial from it it might [ __ ] with
your head
i personally think you should just
ignore it and if you have a smart scale
that is supposed to
assess your body fat percentage you
generally have to stay stepping on it a
little bit longer before it will
actually take that measurement just wait
until the weight number comes up record
that step the [ __ ] off the scale like
don't don't even look at the body fat
percentage number it is not telling you
anything valuable
yeah it is important to recognize like
uh
bioimpedance technology is not a single
thing um so like there are
people working hard at the companies
that develop these technologies to try
to get around some of the challenges
like one thing that you'll see in a lot
of research these days
is
segmental bio bioimpedance spectroscopy
so they're using a spectrum of different
uh
frequencies and they're looking segment
by segment so they'll look at the leg
they'll look at the arm
but i mean that is purely for research
purposes when it comes to
the uh kind of direct to consumer
you know kind of commercial grade uh
bathroom scales
they're they're not implementing any of
those advanced technologies and like you
said it's well and they can't right
right and so with with if i'm working
with a client and they're like well my
bathroom scale i'll be like well let's i
won't cut them off i'll let them finish
but i'll say like let's talk about a
future in which you no longer look at
that number yeah um but yeah
and i'll even say that when it sometimes
they'll be like oh my god eric you're
you're a genius how do you do it i've
gained six pounds of muscle i'll be like
nice but let's also just not
let's not use that yeah yeah
uh all right so that uh does it for the
content in today's episode but to play
us out we've got eric's stat of the day
and this is nba edition i know you're a
big fan of nba basketball
so uh lebron james set a milestone
recently in an otherwise unremarkable
career
he became the
oldest person to average at least 30
points per game over a season in the nba
so
in in honor of this uh milestone
i wanted to quiz you and ask you
so lebron is the oldest person to do
this do you know who the youngest person
to do this is
i think i do
so i think it's lebron it is also lebron
james uh and so
my favorite thing in sports now is just
marveling at
longevity outliers like i wanna watch
tom brady throw a touchdown when he's 56
years old
and to see lebron james
simultaneously being the youngest and
oldest player to ever average 30 points
in a season
it just doesn't make sense i watch these
two guys and i keep saying
there's no way they can keep getting
away with it like this will be the year
where they start falling apart and
they're just they're just incredible
that is true um
so lebron also had another
age-related milestone
uh recently
in that he became the youngest player to
score 37 000 points in a career wow so
that's a lot of points still still a
spring chicken in some respects yeah all
right so i think you have a movie
recommendation yeah yeah i do um so
two nights ago my wife and i went and
saw the new film everything everywhere
all at once um
it would be challenging to
describe the movie in a way that makes
sense and makes it sound good um
it's it's
very trippy
very action-packed and also very
sentimental and touching all at once it
plays with genre really well
goes from being
taking itself very seriously to being
completely absurd
in a way that doesn't feel completely
disjointed and it is i think it's one of
the best movies i've seen in a long long
time so if you
you know if you just want to
take yourself on a date uh have have a
fun movie day or if you want to take
your significant other on a date you
want to go to the movie with the boys
want to go to the movie with the girls i
can't think of a of a
situation or cohort of people that this
would be an inappropriate film for
except maybe very young children um but
yeah it's it's it's a great film that i
think
just about anyone would enjoy and you
should check it out
awesome i'm excited for our show to get
more into film criticism because i know
it's something that's really important
to both of us so
i'm going to start watching some movies
and reviewing them on the show moving
forward
all right so that does it for this
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
as always thank you for joining us and
we hope to see you again very soon
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you